il fallait un plan pour sauver alstom ce
matin christophe sirugue le secrétaire
d'état à l'industrie est venu annoncer
le plan gouvernemental aux principaux
intéressés
l'état s'engage à acheter à sa charge
quinze rames de tgv pour un coût de 450
millions d'euros
elles rouleront sur des lignes
intercités quelques mois de la
présidentielle ont fait n'importe quoi
alors tant mieux tant mieux pour les
gens de belfort et c'est vraiment une
solution industrielle incroyable rythme
on voit que le gouvernement est dans le
bricolage électorat le voir
électoralistes il a fallu à tout prix
trouver une solution cette solution ad
quand même bancale
pourquoi investir dans des tgv pour
desservir des lignes qui n'iront pas à
plus de 200 kilomètres heure c'est comme
si demain
airbus était en difficulté et qu'on
demande à hope qui est la compagnie
régionale d'air france d'acheter des
airbus a380 pour desservir rodez lannion
où agen n'allait pas du bricolage
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
de la part d'un personnage très
important au niveau de l'état qui est
pas loin de moi de la part d'un ancien
ministre des transports monsieur
bussereau qui ne siège pas ici mais même
parfois dans les rangs de la majorité je
pense à monsieur hamon je regrette que
il faille la campagne présidentielle
pour que ce genre de décision serait
prise sur grade le défaut d'anticipation
mais je me réjouis qu'une décision soit
prise qui préserve l'emploi
on voit bien que rien n'est résolu
en catastrophe le gouvernement imagine
une commande plus ou moins artificiel
qui va repousser les échéances de
quelques mois mais qui ne règle pas le
problème structurel d'alstom vous
devriez sur tous les bancs vous réjouir
du maintien du site d'alstom
je trouve indécent si j'arrive à 3
millions de plus j'aurai des gens du
centre
j'aurai des déçus du hollandisme part
quand on est de gauche contre programme
de gauche me semble assez naturel de pas
aller signer un papier on dit qu'on est
de droite et du centre voilà la loyauté
quand on appelle des électeurs de gauche
à venir faute et a signé parjure un
papier dans lequel il s'engagerait à
partager les valeurs de la droite et du
centre
alors qu'en vérité il n'en partagent
aussi c'est facile on va tout de suite
se connaît mais ce qu'on aime pas ce que
j'aime c'est cette énergie
une ex et la superficialité
allemand
simpliste ce satané vous allez soutenir
la candidature de bruno le maire à la
primaire des républicains
j'ai convaincu je croyais paris j'ai
gagné la primaire
rackauckas parier j'ai fait choix du
renouveau et de l'homme qui défend le
renouvellement de la vie politique
française par le maire il n'est pas
moderne
façon à feu
classique est superficiel de voir les
choses